[Music]
welcome to the premiere episode of
between two ponds my name is Ryan
Chester I'm the club manager for the
Saint Louis chess club and we're doing
this show to introduce and spotlight our
grandmasters and residents in our Grand
Master and Residence program and what
that is is a program where we invite
grandmasters to come a st. Louis and
stay and work at the club for about
three to four weeks and we rotate them
in and out they teach other classes do
the private lessons they'll often do
commentary for some of the turns that we
run and whatever miscellaneous needs we
have it's a great way for our members to
interact with players in person and get
various viewpoints from the different
grandmasters as well our program master
is Jessie cry from Santa Fe welcome
so Jessie when'd you become a GM do that
Center do thousand 7:01 okay and then
how long had you been playing before
that oh all my life you know I was a
late starter kind of like Shanklin I
guess right a lot of American kids you
know especially when you grow up in the
middle of nowhere it's hard to even
start so I started late um but yeah I
took some time off from chess I was an
academic for a long time I got one doing
one philosophy
oh wow very philosopher I too might be
in stuff I don't know I saw her great
buddy I did my PhD and then I talked for
a little bit and then I you know got in
my head I just wanted to try to do the
GM type right right which was actually
very much I'm sure what's good so is
that your main thing now like you you're
done with academics you just are I guess
you know I also wrote this chest novel I
you know I don't know if I'll go back to
writing but that was definitely also a
very hard project that I write right
Lieut Lisa right yeah yes it says s
that's awesome basically I think the way
it's worked out is like my life
essentially three pursuits you know I
did the PhD the GM title in the book and
now I have kids so what's next what the
next new thing that's a good question I
would you know I think for me to write
again I would need to have some story
really that urges itself to be right
done this kind of lifestyle here's
pretty good that's right now I got a
glass sound yeah I just well you know I
spent the morning watching the hobby
Magnus game game one right beautiful
Barry and just fine as a fan to watch
everything watch the reactions oh yeah
especially being here single is this is
a neat like atmosphere to be around
wellness is going on and I got was in
London we great but Murray so someone
passionate it was like he was gonna
fistfight because he was like no it's a
bad game I was like no this is a
beautiful game right peddlers so what's
your best chess memory hey probably you
know question but I guess the getting
the GM title when I got it you know
realized they got it was interesting
emotional experience because it was so
hard to do you know I'm not a talented
player and I stopped playing for a while
and all this stuff was so hard to do and
most people I think didn't believe I be
doing it and I think one of those people
was probably myself right right so you
know doing it that's also where was that
it it was Fox since 2007 where was
Foxwoods well Connecticut got again
so who's the strongest player you yes
we're bonus in class well when was that
that was that saved her oh wow
interesting huh so what's your favorite
city
besides st. Louis to play chess in oh
now 70 st. Louis the new line that I'd
like to say is chess players don't have
to die to go to him sir
I feel like when I was in my PhD I
really had a good time I really got
introduced to chess culture traveling
around Germany in the Louvre right
and there's many cities there that have
a beautiful chess culture and every city
so close that you can just go and play
so I guess you know take your pick of
European cities right that's sweet
so what's your favorite opening um these
days you know I'm getting older I'm
having senior moments I can't remember
anything so the openings really aren't
my friend right right right they're not
so did you always want to be a chess
player I guess we kind of covered that
as little your academic stuff but like
we were a kid what did you want to do no
I think definitely when I was the kid a
certain moment I realized I really
wanted to do it and you know contrast it
today is kind of interesting back home
because and then every voice around you
whether you know teachers parents
whatever they were all just basically
like no you can't do this
yeah you know this is just a game
or something like that and so you know
then there was this situation where you
know I either go to college or play
chess and I wasn't that great I was like
twenty three fifty years right and
graduate high school we just may be
higher than that now is it's a rating
inflation right everybody but still I
wasn't like some star person and so the
idea to like go for it it's hard to
fathom because there was no support
structure right nowhere I was
encouraging me to do it yeah so that was
like college of the default comes what's
your favorite gamey science chess that's
in question um whether it be border you
know anything
I you know I have friends who've tried
to get me into go oh okay and it feels
like I'm cheating on my wife if I give
you K yeah also it feels like just
there's chess is enough for me the other
games of other games I actually feel
like it's more than enough
so I'm not really interested right yeah
if you want to get me to play D&D some
nightmare you got that but I'm not
that's just gonna be one night right not
another not a passion
lastly who's your favorite employee of
the club employee of the club that's an
interesting question
Brian jester there's a lot of
interesting stories in the club of
people who work there and you know here
I'm just I've been here a week right I
feel like if I stayed here longer I'd
get a deeper sense yes these people are
yeah yeah it's an interesting group of
people that have come together yes oh
all right well that is all the time we
have for today Thank You Jesse very much
our next grant pastor big Vladimir's
Georgiev so if any questions please
email us and we can ask them let you
know if you have any questions for Jesse
we can do a follow-up as well if other
than that thank you very much
[Music]
you